[Music]
okay so can you imagine the insanity if
Whoopi Goldberg and Tiffany Haddish play
mother and daughter in a movie well
here's the deal you don't have to
imagine it because Carly Steele got this
I mean this is going to be amazing and I
spoke to the movie mogul who is making
this comedy dream team a reality the one
and only Tyler Perry Tiffany Haddish you
guys are gonna be working together the
movies called the list Whoopi Goldberg
explained her mother so the two of them
get to work together nobody knows that
yes you're the first one to know it's
gonna be really fun Tiffany starred in
Tyler's TV series if loving he was wrong
back in 2015 before landing her breakout
role in girls trip last year now she's
hanging with the likes of Bay and Jay I
got invited so to be out by party and of
course the 38 year old is currently at
the center of the hoobat beyonce mystery
Tyler says he knows who did it but his
lips are staying sealed but the 48 year
old dad is dishing about his recent
bidding war with six-year-old Blue Ivy
at a charity auction she's bidding every
every painting that came out she was
like you would hear her in the whole
audience I want that so I decided the
audience would laughing thought it was
funny I'm like no I'm gonna teach you a
lesson I'm gonna take this painting from
you who better to learn from than a man
whose films have made more than eight
hundred and seventy three million
worldwide and in his new movie acrimony
Tyler's directing taraji P Henson as a
woman who scorned
Ankit acrimony means bitterness and
anger so we had to play our own word
game if you could come up with a word to
describe taraji what would it be
so Rajan would definitely be brilliant
aful really high uh Virgo cuz that's
what he is but he is a verb go uh I'm a
Leo in the Virgo cusp and let me tell
you virgos are perfectionist they're
very detail-oriented
what are you drop the cusp within there
I'm Kevin and I'm a Taurus
[Music]
[Applause]